constate quand même c'est quand il ya un
événement important les gens reviennent
aux médias traditionnels
on le constate à peu près dans tous les
médias traditionnels il ya plus
d'audience télévision radio presse
écrite à tout lui revient
puis ensuite tout petit dernier mot on
peut pas mettre je pense tous les
réseaux sociaux dans le même sac et et
pour venir à twitter on pourrait passer
l'émission entière et moi je crois
qu'effectivement particulièrement et
twitter il ya un double effet soufflé au
fromage c'est à dire qu'il ya des trucs
qui monte en épingle comme ça
extrêmement vie de façon de chasser
excessive et d'autre part twitter il ya
des études américaines là dessus qui lui
montre c'est une caisse de
rétrécissement de l'information sa
n'élargit pas votre champ de
l'information ça le récit parce que de
fait c'est la même chose que le soufflé
au fromage
il ya des sujets qui monte qui monte qui
monte mais en fait c'est un petit nombre
de sujets qui étaient traités par haine
par une petite partie de la population
donc twitter ne vous donne pas une image
très juste de du monde environnant